[Musique]
oh
clic du match où nous écouter anonyme
écouter climbach écho au riu
mais calais ap mike aviles m'écouter
amis au pays et marie caillou barbaro
allèles à la mario news
[Applaudissements]
des peuples indigènes livrés à eux mêmes
avec des structures censées les protéger
tout à fait chancelante et pas du tout à
la hauteur des défis en ce qui concerne
le brésil on sait que monsieur molson
arts où le président a tout à fait de
façon délibérée fragiliser les
structures étatiques censée protéger les
indigènes donc la funai la fondation
nationale de l'indien et pas seulement
les d'ailleurs les structures pour les
indigènes mais aussi des structures qui
protègent l'environnement l'ibama qui
est un institut qui compte l
environnement il a coupé donc les vivres
à pratiquement tous ces organismes
oh
[Musique]
à l'accès aux soins il serait quasiment
impossible c'est pour ça qu'il faut
éviter absolument la contamination
pourquoi bah c'est simple si vous avez
un cas qui se déclarent en plein milieu
de la forêt ça va pas être un cas
d'ailleurs ça va être plusieurs
comment vous allez faire il ya des
endroits où on peut même pas se poser en
avion il ya des endroits où on est
obligé de prendre de faire plusieurs
heures de barques des jacobins
logistique déjà impressionnante
il faudra une valeur volonté politique
immense qui n'existe pas et il faudrait
des fonds lui faudra beaucoup de fonds
à
[Musique]
ce sont en effet immédiatement mis en
position de confinement lors ce qui
concerne le cacique ravony ça a été
beaucoup plus loin puisque il a
immédiatement demandé à ce que les
routes autour d'eux des terres indigènes
qui le concerne soit coupée en ce qui
concerne les gestes barrières les
peuples indigènes sont habitués parce
que malheureusement ils ont été frappés
par par un nombre de maladies important
des épidémies vous savez que depuis
depuis le premier contact
ils ont été décimées il ya certes
certains chercheurs qui estiment que 95%
des indigènes vivant avant le premier
contact avait disparu lors de la seconde
vague mais disons que beaucoup d'entre
eux ont en effet une habitude déjà de
cette distanciation et quand quelqu'un
arrive vous rendre malade il est au
milieu de façon un peu naturel en
quarantaine
[Musique]
la situation est critique et que
finalement n'oublions jamais derrière
tout ça c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça
notre campagne aussi protégeant les
gardiens c'est que ces gens là sont les
gardiens de l'amazone il est gardien de
des autres écosystèmes de la région et
ses écosystèmes on n'a plus besoin de
prouver maintenant c'est ils sont
importants pour le grand combat du
siècle qui est la lutte contre le
changement climatique